american people would still not be in
that option number one with bernie
sanders
far left on the manifesto
as you socialize medicine look hey are
you still not gonna
listen to him the fact of the matter is
i beat bernie sanders
not very much i've beat him a whole hell
of a lot i'm here i'm here standing
facing you
the hunters would have left two days
early you would have lost every price
well he knows how to introduce
tuesday you got to look very little
there's a deal i got very lucky and
very lucky tonight as well and tonight
i'm going to make sure
because here's the deal here's the deal
the fact is that everything he's saying
so far is simply a lie
i'm not here to call out his lies
everybody knows he's a liar but you
i just want him to tell you
can you let him finish sir no he doesn't
know how to do that he has
you know christ you picked your surprise
there is no manifesto number please let
him speak mr number two
just lost the left number two you just
lost the left
you agreed bernie
he is not for any help for people
needing health care because his because
he in fact already has cost
people their health care got the
question from their employers because of
his recession
number one number two there are 20
million people getting health care
through obamacare now
that he wants to take it away he won't
ever look in eye and say that's what he
wants to do
take it away oh i want to give numbers
to health care at a much lower price
because
he doesn't know how he doesn't know
go ahead sir obamacare is no good we
made it better and i had a choice to
make very early on
we took away the individual mandate we
guarantee pre-existing conditions but
took away the individual mandate
listen this is the way it is and that
destroyed
that they shouldn't even call it
obamacare then i had a choice to make do
i let my people run it really well
or badly if i run it badly they'll
probably blame him but they'll blame me
but more importantly i want to help
people
okay i said you got to run it so well
that's amazing and i just had a meeting
with them they said the problem is no
matter how well
you run obamacare it's a disaster it's
too expensive
premiums are too high that it doesn't
work
we do want to get out of it i understand
that
wishful thinking he has executive orders
he does not have a plan he doesn't have
a plan
and the fact is this man doesn't know
what he's talking about
all right i have one final question for
you sure uh mr vice president
if senate republicans we were talking
originally about the supreme court here
if senate republicans go ahead and
confirm
justice barrett uh there has been talk
about ending the filibuster or even
packing the court
adding to the nine justices there you
call this a distraction by the president
but in fact it wasn't brought up by the
president
it was brought up by some of your
democratic colleagues and i'm saying the
congress
so my question to you is you have
refused in the past to talk about it
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not you will
support
either ending the filibuster or packing
whatever position i take in that that'll
become the issue the issue is the
american people should speak
you should go out and vote this is good
that he's doing we're in voting now
says very good let your senators know
how do you feel
i'm not going to answer the question
because because the question is
the question is radical left would you
shut up
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second section
or no oh yeah that's a good look but
that's his only defense
let's try to be serious about it we have
had more than seven
million cases of corona viruses in the
united states
more than two hundred thousand people
have died even
after we produce a vaccine experts say
that it wasn't
before we come back to anything
approaching
normal my question for both of you is
based on what you have said
and done so far and what you have said
you would do starting
in 2021 why should the american people
trust you
more than your opponent to deal with
this
public health crisis going forward in
this case
the question goes to you first sir two
minutes uninterrupted
good luck two hundred thousand dollars
that's good i like to said over seven
million
exactly in the united states we in fact
have
five percent four percent of the world's
population twenty percent of the deaths
we know the staff
thousand people a day you gotta hear the
story contracting
in addition to that about between seven
fifty and a thousand people today are
dying
when he was presented with that number
he said it is what it is
okay but it is what it is because you
are well played
that's why it is because
it is what it is because you are who you
are that's very has this stuff
all the way back in february how serious
this crisis was
he knew it was a deadly disease you are
who you are tape is acknowledging you
knew it he said he didn't tell us or
give people a warning of it
because he didn't want to panic the
american people you don't panic
he panicked in addition to that
he went in and he we were insisting that
the chinese
the people we had on the ground in china
should be able to go to wuhan
and determine for themselves how
dangerous this was
he did not even ask she to do that he
told us what a great job
she was doing he said we owe him a debt
of gratitude
for being so transparent that is true
then he died he waited and waited and
waited he still doesn't have a plan
i laid out back in march exactly what we
should be doing
and i laid out again in july what we
we should be providing all the
protective gear pods we should be
providing the money the house has passed
in order to be able to go out and get
people the help they need to keep their
businesses open
open schools that cost a lot of money
you should get out of your bunker and
get out of the sand trap and get in
in your golf course and go in the oval
office and bring together the democrats
republicans and fund what needs to be
done now to save
lives
two minutes sir if we would have
listened to you
the country would have been left wide
open millions of people would have died
not 200 000
and one person is too much it's china's
fault it should have never happened
they stopped it from going in but it was
china's fault and by the way when you
talk about numbers you don't know how
many people died in china
you don't know how many people died in
russia you don't know how many people
died in india they don't exactly give
you a straight count just so you
understand
but if you look at what we've done i
closed it and you said he's xenophobic
he's a racist and he's xenophobic
because you didn't think i should have
closed our country wait a minute it says
two minutes you didn't think we should
have closed our country because you
thought it was too
it was terrible you wouldn't have closed
it for another two months
by my doing it early in fact dr fauci
said
president trump saved thousands of lives
many of you a democrat governor said
president trump did a phenomenal job we
worked with the governor oh really go
take a look
the governor said i did a phenomenal job
most of them
we're doing therapeutics already fewer
people are dying when they get weeks
away from a vaccine
like that we've done a great job the
only thing i haven't done a good job and
that's because of the fake news
no matter what you say to them they give
you a bad press on it's just fake news
they give you good press they give me
bad press because that's the way it is
unfortunately but let me just tell you
something i don't care i've gotten used
to it
but i'll tell you joe you could never
have done the job that we did okay
you don't have it in your blood you
could have never done that that's a
measured response i know how
to do the job i know how to get the job
well you didn't do very well in swine
flu
h1n1 you were a disaster your own
children
were in disaster 14 000 people died not
200 000 there was no
economic
shut down is because look you folks at
home how many of you get up this morning
and had an empty chair at the kitchen
table because someone died of covet
boom how many of you were in a situation
where you're lost you're doing good
right i'm your dad and you couldn't even
speak tonight
this is what trump can't do
held him he said if we just where we
could save
half those numbers just the math he said
both sounds like this
i don't trust him at all i agree with
you i know you do shout out to jesus
let me move on to questions about the
future because you both have touched on
one of the
two of the questions i'm going to ask
focusing
for disease control dr redfield said it
would be summer
before the vaccine would become
generally available
to the public you said that he was
confused
and mistaken those were your two words
but
dr slowly the head of your operation
worf speed
has said exactly the same thing are they
both wrong well i've spoken to the
companies and we can have it a lot
sooner it's a very political thing
because people like this
would rather make it political than save
lives it is a very political thing
i've spoken to pfizer i've spoken to all
of the people that you have to speak to
we have great
moderna johnson and johnson and others
they can go faster than that by a lot
become very political because the left
or i don't know
your left i don't know what the head of
your operation warp speed doctor
i disagree with him yeah no i disagree
with both of them and he didn't say that
he said it could be there but it could
also be much you know i had him in my
office two days
he talked about the summer sir before
it's generally available
she said it's a possibility that we'll
have the answer
before november first it could also be
generally available well we're going to
deliver it right away we have the
military all set up logistically they're
all set up
we have our military that delivers
soldiers and they can do two hundred
thousand a day
they're going to be this is the same man
it's all set up
by easter this would be gone away by the
warm weather it'd be gone
miraculous like a miracle and by the way
maybe you could inject some bleach in
your arm and that would take care of
this sarcastic that was you know that i
would have said sarcasm
so here's the deal this man is talking
about a vaccine
every serious every serious company is
talking about
maybe having a vaccine done by the end
of the year but the distribution of that
vaccine
will not occur until sometime beginning
or the middle of next year to get it out
if i get the vaccine and pray god we
will say god
obama came
contributing to that fear
is holding his own yeah
there's millions of scientists there's
thousands of scientists out there
like here at this great hospital that
don't work for him
their job doesn't depend on him that's
not
they're the people there and by the way
to the scientists that are in charge by
the way they will have the vaccine very
seriously
do you believe for a moment what he's
telling me in light of
he still hasn't even acknowledged that
he knew
this was happening knew how dangerous
was going to be
back in february and he didn't even tell
you
he's on record as saying it he panicked
or he just looked at the stock market
one of the two
because guess what a lot of people died
and a lot more going to die unless he
gets a lot smarter a lot quicker
mr president beer monster you use the
word smart
uh so you said you went to delaware
state but you forgot the name of your
college
you didn't go to delaware state you
graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't ever use the word
smart with me don't ever use that word
oh
give me that because you know what and
there's nothing smart about you
47 years ago if you would have had let
me just tell you something
six year old if you would have had we
have our presence
i was put through i had to close the
greatest economy in the history of our
country
and by the way now it's being built
again it's going to get to the economy
in the next segment sir
okay it's going up fast okay when it
comes to how
the virus has been handled so far the
two of you have taken very different
approaches and this is going to affect
how the virus is handled going forward
by
whichever of you ends up becoming the
next president i want to quickly go
through several of those reopenings
vice president biden you have been much
more reluctant than president trump
about reopening the economy and schools
why sir
because he doesn't have a plan if i were
running i know how what the plan is
you've got to provide these businesses
the ability to have the money to be able
to reopen with the ppe
as well as with the sanitation they need
you have to provide them to nazi pelosi
well he's just shush for a minute tell
us
nancy pelosi and schumer they have a
plan
he won't even meet with him the
republicans won't meet with the senate
but he he sits he sits in his golf
course
i mean literally think about it you
probably play more than i do
what about those questions of reopenings
and the fact that he wants to
shut down this country and i want to
keep it open
and we did a great job wait a minute let
me shut you down for a second joe just
for one second
we want to he wants to shut down the
country we just went through it we had
to because we didn't know anything about
the disease now we found
that elderly people with heart problems
and diabetes and different problems are
very very vulnerable we learned a lot
young children aren't
even younger people aren't we've learned
a lot but he wants to shut it down
more people will be hurt by continuing
if you look at pennsylvania if you look
at certain states
that have been shut down they have
democrat governors all one of the
reasons they're shut down is because
they want to keep it shut down until
after the election
november because i wanted to go into
another country
but those states those states are not
doing well that are shut down
you have begun to increasingly question
the effectiveness
of masks as a disease preventer and in
fact recently you have cited
the issue of waiters touching their mass
and touching plates
are you questioning no i think they'll
be asking you
you have to understand if you look i
mean i have a mask right here i put a
mask on it
you know when i think i need it tonight
as an example everybody's had a test
and you've had social distancing and all
of the things that you have to but
i wear masks when needed when needed i
wear a mask
okay let me ask i don't have to i don't
wear mess like him every time you see
him he's got a mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from me he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
the way to open businesses is give them
the wherewithal to be able open
we provided money that kind of i was
asking a sir about masks
well mask must make a big difference his
own head of cdc said if we just more
mass between now
if they're everybody more mass in social
distance between now and january
we'd probably save up to a hundred
thousand lives
it matters and they've also said the
opposite they've also said no
no serious person said the opposite no
seriously dr fauci said that he did
i want to ask you guys a minute left in
this assessments are not good
then he changed his mind he said i'm
okay with masks
subject because your different
approaches has even affected the way
that you have campaigned
president trump you're holding large
rallies with crowds packed together
thousands of people i would say outside
yes sir agreed uh vice president
biden you are holding much smaller uh
events with
nobody will show up people with math
nobody shows up to israel in any case
why are you
holding the big rallies why you not
people
buddy because people want to hear what i
have to say i mean but are you not
worried about me and i'll have 25 35 000
people show up
at airports we use airports are you not
worried about we have a lot of people
well so far we have had no problem
whatsoever it's outside that's a big
difference according to people
experts we do them outside we have
tremendous
crowds as you see you know everybody's
talking about
literally on 24 hours notice events and
joe does the circles and has three
people some players okay
one of the last reviews and the reporter
came up to me
asking a question he said no no no stand
back put on your mask
put on a mask have you been tested i'm
way
i'm way far away from those other people
that's what he said
i can't i'm going to be okay he's not
worried about you
he's not worried about the people out
there breathing in one of them we've had
no negativity
no negative effect we've had no negative
effect and we've had
thirty five forty thousand right people
wanted israelis just quickly finish up
because i wanna move on to our next yes
i would he's been totally irresponsible
the way in which he has handled
the social distancing and people wearing
masks basically encourage them not to
all right then he's a fool if you could
get the crowds you would have done the
same thing but you can't nobody can
gentlemen can we move on to the
appearance gentlemen can we move on to
the economy yes
the economy is i think it's fair to say
recovering
faster than expected shutdown
in the second quarter the unemployment
rate fell to 8.4
last month the federal reserve says the
hit
to growth which is going to be there is
not going to be nearly
as big as they had expected president
trump you say we are in a v-shaped
recovery vice president biden you say
it's more of a k-shape
what difference does that mean to the
american people in terms of the economy
president trump in this
segment you go first so we built the
greatest economy in history we closed it
down because of the china plague when
the plague came in we closed it down
which was
very hard psychologically to do he
didn't think we should close it down and
he was wrong
and again two million people would be
dead now instead of
still 204 thousand people is too much
one person is too much should have never
happened from china
but what happened is we closed it down
and now we're reopening and we're doing
record business
we had 10.4 million people in a
four-month period that we've
put back into the workforce that's a
record the likes of which nobody's ever
seen before
and he wants to close down the he will
shut it down again he will destroy this
country
you know a lot of people between drugs
and alcohol and
depression when you start shutting it
down you take a look at what's happening
at some of your democrat-run states
where they have these
tough shutdowns and i'm telling you it's
because they don't want to open it one
of them came out last week you saw that
oh we're going to open up on november
9th why november 9th because it's after
the election
they think they're hurting us by keeping
them close they're hurting people
people know what to do they can social
distance they can wash their hands they
can wear masks
they can do whatever they want but
they've got to open these states up
when you look at north carolina when you
look and these governors are under siege
pennsylvania michigan and a couple of
others
you've got to open these states up it's
not fair you're talking about almost
it's like being in prison
and you look at what's going on with
divorce look at what's going on with
alcoholism and drugs it's a very very
sad thing
and he'll close down the whole country
this guy will close down the whole
country
and destroy our country our country is
coming back incredibly well
setting records as it does it we don't
need somebody to come in and say let's
shut it down
all right you're two minutes sir we're
now moved to you
as i as i said posing the question the
president says it's a v-shaped recovery
you say it's a k-shaped
recovery what's the difference the
difference is
millionaires and billionaires like him
in the middle of a cover crisis
billionaire
had done very well nine million another
billionaires of ray have
made another 300 billion dollars because
of his
profligate tax proposal and
they only focus on the market but you
folks at home here we go
you folks living in scranton and
claymont and all the small towns and
working-class towns in america
how old are you doing this guy paid well
total of 750 dollars in taxes
right now i understand you've agreed to
the two minutes so please let them have
it do i get my time back
the fact is that he has in fact worked
on this in a way that he's going to be
the first president united states
to leave office having fewer jobs in his
administration than when he became
president
fewer jobs than when he became friends
first one in american history
secondly the people who have lost all
the people
are those people who have been on the
front lines those people who have been
saving our
the idea that he is insisting that we
go forward and open when you have almost
half the states in america with a
significant increase
in covert deaths and covert cases in the
united states of america
and he wants to open it up more why does
he want to open it up why doesn't he
take care of the america you can't fix
the economy
until you fix the covet crisis and he
has no
intention of doing anything about making
it better for you all
at home in terms of your health and your
safety school
because it costs a lot of money to open
them safely you know
they were going to give his
administration going to give the
teachers and school
students masks and then they decided no
couldn't do that because it's not a
national emergency
not a national emergency they've done
nothing to help
small businesses nothing they're closing
one in six is now gone
right now he ought to get on the job and
take care of the needs of the american
people
so we can't open safely your time is
observed we're going to get to
i have to respond to that well you both
had two minutes sir
excuse me he made a statement people
want their schools no
people want their schools open they
don't want to be shut down they don't
want their estate shut down they want
their restaurants i look at new york
it's so sad what's happening in new york
it's almost like a ghost town
and i'm not sure it can ever recover
what they've done in new york
people want their places open they want
to get back to their lives people
they'll be careful but they want their
schools
i'm the one that brought back football
by the way i brought back big ten
mr president as you well know there's a
new report
that in 2016 the year you were elected
president and 2017
your first year as president that you
paid 750
a year in federal income this each of
those years
i know that you pay a lot of other taxes
but i'm asking you the specific question
is it true that you paid 750 dollars
millions of dollars in taxes millions of
dollars
of income tax and let me just tell you
there was a story in one of the papers
that was your tax i paid 38 million
dollars
one year i paid 27 million show us your
tax returns
i went uh you'll see it as soon as it's
finished you'll see it right yeah if you
want to do it
that says everything i have every bank i
have i'm totally
under leveraged because the assets are
extremely good
and we have a very we have a we i built
i'm asking you a specific question which
is let me tell you
i understand all of that no
mr president i'm asking you a question
will you tell us
how much you paid in federal income
taxes
in 2016 and 2017. millions of dollars
you paid millions of dollars millions of
dollars so millions of dollars and
you'll get to see it
and you'll get to see it but let chris
let me just tell you something that
it was the tax laws i don't want to pay
tax be
before i came here i was a private
developer i was a private business
people
like every other private person unless
they're stupid
they go through the laws and that's what
it is he passed a tax bill
that gave us all these privileges for
depreciation
and for tax credits we built a building
and we get tax credits like the hotel
on pennsylvania avenue you get a massive
which by the way was given to me
by the obama administration if you can
believe that
now the man got fired right after that
happened but did president biden want to
respond
yeah i do want to respond look the tax
code
that made him put him in a position
that he pays less tax than a school
teacher make
them on the money a school teacher makes
is because of
him take he says he's smart because he
can take advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts and we're going to we're going to
eliminate those taxes
you're going to raise taxes and make
sure that we invest in the people who in
fact
need the help people out there
i've done more than you've done in 47
years
we've done things that you've never even
thought about including fixing the
broken military that you gave me
mr president we're talking about the
economy i'd like to ask you about
your plans going forward because mr vice
president your economic plan
if you were to be elected president uh
focuses a lot on big government big
taxes
big spending i want to focus first on
the taxes
you propose more than four trillion
dollars over a decade in new taxes
on individuals making more than four
hundred thousand dollars a year and
on corporations president trump says
that that kind of an
increase in taxes is going to hurt the
economy as it's just coming out of a
recession well just take a look at what
has the the analysis has been on by
firms
points out that my my economic plan
would create seven million more jobs
than his in four years number one
and number two it would create an
additional one trillion dollars in
economic growth because it would be
about
buying american that we have to we're
going to make this federal government
spend 600 billion dollars here on
everything from
ships to steel to buildings and the like
and under my proposal we're going to
make sure that every penny of that
has to be made by a company respectfully
so i'm talking about taxes
by the way i'm going to eliminate a
significant number of the tax i'm going
to make the
the the corporate tax 28 it shouldn't be
you have 19 companies 91 companies
federal i mean and the fortune 500 you
don't pay a single penny
tax making billions of dollars
because because you in fact pass this if
you can go to
that was your tax report you got it done
and you know what happened you got it
down our economy boom
mr president let me pick up on that you
would continue
your free market approach lower taxes
more
deregulation correct not lower taxes
american people
but in but in obama's you talk about the
economy booming
it turns out that in obama's final three
years as president
more jobs were created a million and a
half more
jobs than in the first three years of
your presidency they had the slowest
recovery since night economic recovery
since 1929
it was the slowest recovery also they
took over something that was down here
all you had to do was turn on the lights
and you pick up a lot
but they had the slowest economic
recovery since 1929 let me tell you
about the stock market
when the stock market goes up that means
jobs it also means 401ks
if you got in if you ever became
president with your ideas you want to
terminate my tax
my taxes i i'll tell you what you'll
lose half of the companies that have
poured in here
will leave and plenty of companies that
are already here they'll leave for other
places
they will leave and you will have a
depression the likes of which
you've never seen look we inherited
the worst recession short of a
depression in american history
i was asked to bring it back we were
able to have an economic recovery that
created the jobs you're talking about
we handed him a booming economy he blew
it wasn't he blew it he wasn't booming
wait wait is it is it fair to say he
blew it when
in fact it was right you know when there
was record on low unemployment yeah
before covet
yeah but because what he did even before
covent manufacturing went in the hole
manufacturing went nut whole excuse
number one
number two number three they said they
would take no you were number two no
chris chris they said it was a miracle
to bring back manufacturing i brought
back seven hundred thousand jobs
they brought back nothing they gave up
on manufacturing
standard fare i'm the guy he totally
gave up on manufacturing all right let
him know we brought back
i was asked to bring back chrysler and
general motors who brought him back
right here in the state of ohio in
michigan
he blew it they're gone he blew it and
in fact
they're gone ohio had the best year it's
ever had last year
michigan had the best year they've ever
had it's not
and so you take a look at what he's
actually done he's done
very little his trade deals are the same
way he talks about these great trade
deals
you know he talks about the art of the
deal china has made perfected the art of
the steel
we have a higher deficit with china now
than we did before
we have the highest deficit trade
deficit
and no wonder your son goes in and he
takes out
he takes out billions of dollars takes
out billions of dollars to manage he
makes millions of dollars
and also while we're at it why is it
just out of curiosity
the mayor of moscow's wife gave your son
three and a half million dollars
what did he do to deserve it what did he
do with baristas
totally discredited and by the way well
wait he didn't get three half million
dollars joe mister
he got 300
my son did nothing wrong at first i
think he did mr president
he doesn't want to let me answer because
he knows i have the truth his position
has been totally
thoroughly discussed by everybody well
by the media by our allies by the world
bank
by everyone as discredited matter of
fact
matter of fact people who testified
look here's the deal we want to talk
about families
and ethics i don't want to do that i
mean his family we could talk about all
night his family is our family
my family lost a fortune coming down and
helping us with government and that's
such a direction
mr president single one of them this is
not about
my family or his family it's about your
family
america he doesn't that's not true it
doesn't
want to talk about what you need
you the american people it's about you
that's what we're talking about all
right
that's the end of the segment we're
moving on it didn't take them
vice president can i be honest it's a
very important try to be honest
no the answer to the question is no
ukraine no i
sir with a billion dollars if you've
asked for it you know what you're okay
you're doing it you're gonna have true
gentlemen
i hate to raise my voice but it seems to
me why shouldn't i be different than the
two of you
so here's the deal we have
f six segments we have ended that
segment we're going to go to the next
segment
in that segment you wish you're going to
have two uninterrupted moments
in those two interrupted minutes mr
president you can say anything you want
i've been asked a question about race
but if you want to answer about
something else go ahead
good we think the country would be
better served
if we allowed both people to speak with
fewer interruptions i'm appealing to you
sir to do
honestly the viewers wanted you to take
control frankly you've been doing more
interruptions that's all right but he
does plenty
well less than less than no less than
you have
let's please continue on the issue of
race
vice president biden you say that
president trump's response to the
violence
in charlottesville three years ago when
he talked about
very fine people on both sides was what
directly
led you to launch this run for president
oh yeah sure
president trump you have often said that
you believe you have done
more for black americans than any
president with the possible exception
of abraham lincoln my question for the
two of you is why should voters trust
you rather than your opponent to deal
with the race issues facing this country
over the next four years
vice president biden you go first this
question it's about equity
inequality it's about decency it's about
the constitution and we have never
walked away from
trying to quit requiring equity for
everyone equality for the whole
of america but we've never accomplished
it but we've never
walked away from it like he has done it
is true the reason i got in the races
with those people close your eyes
remember what those people look like
coming out of the fields carrying
torches
their veins bulging speeding just
spewing anti-semitic
bile and accompanied by the ku klux klan
a young woman got killed
and they asked the president what he
thought he said were very fine people on
both sides
no president has ever said anything like
that
now second sir second point i'd make to
you
is that when floyd was killed when mr
floyd was killed
there was a peaceful protest in front of
the white house what did he do
he came out of his bunker had the
military do
use tear gas on him so he could walk
across to a church and hold up a bible
and then
what happened after that the bishop of
that very church said
that it was the disgrace the general who
was with him said
he only all he ever wants to do is
divide people not unite people at all
this is a president who has used
everything as a dog whistle
to try to generate racist hatred racist
division
this is a man who in fact you talk about
helping african americans
one in one thousand african-americans
has been
killed but because of the conan they're
throwing away thanks to see you just
yeah
it doesn't do something quickly by the
end of the year one in
500 will have been that's a terrible one
this man this man is the as a savior of
african americans
this man cares at all this man's done
virtually nothing look the fact is that
you have to
look at what he talks about you have to
look at what he did
and what he did has been disastrous for
the african-american community so
president trump you have two minutes why
should americans
trust you over your opponent to deal
with racism did a crime bill
1994 yes where you call them super
predators
african americans the super predators
and they've never forgotten it
they've never forgotten it you've never
seen no sir it's his two minutes so you
did that
and they called you super predator and
i'm letting people out of jail now that
you have treated the african-american
population
about as bad as anybody in this country
you did the 1999 and that's why
if you look at the polls i'm doing
better than any republican has done in a
long time
because they saw what you did you call
them super predators
and you've called them worse than that
because you look back at your testimony
over the years you've called them a lot
worse than that as far as the church is
concerned
and as far as the generals are concerned
we just got the support of 200
mil 250 military leaders and generals
total support law enforcement almost
every law enforcement
group in the united states i have
florida i have texas
i have ohio i have every
excuse me portland the sheriff just came
out today and he said i support
president trump i don't think you have
any law enforcement you can't even say
the word law enforcement because if you
say those words
you're going to lose all of your radical
left supporters and why aren't you
saying those words
why don't you say the words law
enforcement because you know what if
they called us in portland
we would put out that fire in a half an
hour but they won't do it because
they're run by radical left democrats
if you look at chicago if you look at
any place you want to look seattle they
heard we were coming in the following
day and they put up their hands and we
got back seattle
minneapolis we got it back because we
believe in law and order
just about the top 40 cities these are
really really run by
democrats in many cases radically and
they've got you wrapped around their
finger joke
to a point where you don't want to say
anything about law enforcement
and i'll tell you what the people of
this country want
and demand law and order and you're
afraid to even say it
all right let's see what he's done to
the question of race
vice president biden after the grand
jury and the brianna i want to give her
decided not to charge any of the police
with homicide you said it raises the
question
quote whether justice could be equally
applied
in america do you believe that there is
a separate but
unequal system of justice for blacks in
this country
yes there is there's just systemic
injustice
in this country in education and work
and in
in law enforcement and and the way in
which it's enforced
but look the vast majority of police
officers are good decent honorable men
and women
they risk their lives every day to take
care of us but there are some bad apples
and when they occur when they find them
they have to be
sorted out they have to be held
accountable they have to be held
accountable
and what i'm going to do as president
united states is called a
together an entire group of people at
the white house
blow everything from the civil rights
groups to the police officers the police
chiefs
and we're going to work this out we're
going to work this out so we change the
way in which we have more transparency
and when these things happen there it is
cops aren't happy to see what happened
to
to george floyd these cops aren't happy
to see what happened to
brianna taylor most don't like it but we
have to have a system
where people are held accountable when
and by the way trump's violence and
response
is never appropriate never appropriate
peaceful protest is
violence is never appropriate right what
is peaceful protest
when they run through the town burn down
your stores
i promise we're going to get to the
issue of law and order in a moment
this month your administration directed
federal agencies to end
racial sensitivity training that
addresses
white privilege or critical race theory
why did you decide to do that to end
racial sensitivity training
and do you believe that there is
systemic racism in this country sir
i ended it because it's racist i ended
it because a lot of people were
complaining that they were
asked to do things that were absolutely
insane
that it was a radical revolution that
was taking place
in our military uh in our schools
all over the place and you know it and
so does everybody else
talk about racial sensitivity training
if you were a certain person
you had no status in life it was sort of
a reversal
and if you look at the people we were
paying people hundreds of thousands of
dollars
to teach very bad ideas and frankly very
sick ideas
and and really they were teaching people
to hate our country
and i'm not going to do that i'm not
going to allow that to happen that's
right
we have to go back to the core values of
this country
they were teaching people that our
country is a horrible place it's a
racist place
and they were teaching people to hate
our country and i'm not going to allow
that to happen
vice president biden nobody's doing that
he's just
he's the racist you just don't here's
the deal i know a lot more about it
the fact is that there is racial
insensitivity people have to be made
aware
of what other people feel like what
what insults them what is but we don't
need a government
it's important that people know they
don't want to do it many people don't
want to
hurt other people it makes a big
difference we don't need to be making a
gigantic difference in the way of
children
grow up in heaven it's a little bit like
how
this guy and his friends look down on so
many people
look down their nose on people like
irish catholics like me and grow up in
scranton they look down on people who
don't have money they look down on
people
who are of a different faith they look
down on people
who are a different color in fact we're
all americans the only way we're going
to bring this country together
is bring everybody together there's
nothing we cannot do
if we do it together we can take this on
and we can defeat
racism president i mean president trump
sir during the obama
biden administration there was
tremendous division
there was hatred you look at ferguson
you look at
you go to very many places look at
oakland look what happened in oakland
look what happened in baltimore look
what happened
frankly it was more violent than what
i'm even seeing now but the reason
is that the democrats that run these
cities
don't want to talk like you about law
and order violence you still haven't
mentioned violence are you in favor of
law and order i'm in favor of law you
follow
are you in favor of the law you asked
the question
with justice where people get treated
fairly and the fact of the matter is
violent crime went down
17 15 in our administration
oh it's gone up on his watch he's much
more he has all right
mr president mr president every record
mr president you're going to be very
happy because we're not going to talk
about law enormously
in trouble with democratic-run cities
that's exactly my question there has
been a dramatic increase in homicides in
america
this summer particularly and you often
blame that on democratic
mayors and democratic governors but in
fact there have been equivalent
spikes in republican-led cities like
tulsa and fort worth
so the question is is this really a
party issue
i think it's a party issue you can bring
in a couple of examples but if you look
at chicago what's going on in chicago
where
53 people were shot and eight died shot
if you look at new york where it's going
up like nobody's ever seen anything the
numbers are going up 100 150
200 percent uh crime it is
crazy what's going on and he doesn't
want to say law and order because he
can't
because he'll lose his radical left
supporters and once he does that it's
over with but
if he ever got to run this country and
they ran it the way he would want to run
it
we would have our suburbs would be gone
by the way
our suburbs would be gone and you would
see problems like
he would have no suburb unless he took a
wrong turn oh i know celebrities
go ahead was raised in the suburbs this
is not 1950.
all these dog whistles on racism don't
work anymore suburbs are by and large
integrated there's many people today
driving their kids to soccer practice
and or to
black and white and hispanic in the same
car as there have been any time
in the past what's what really is a
threat to the suburbs and their safety
is his failure to deal with covet
they're dying in the suburbs
his failure to deal with the environment
they're being flooded
they're being burned out because his
refusal to do anything
that's why the suburbs are interested i
do want to talk about this issue of law
and order though and
in the joint recommendation that came
from the
biden bernie sanders task force you
talked about
quote reimagining policing
first of all what does reimagining
policing mean and do you support
it let me if i might finish the question
what does reimagining policing mean
and do you support the black lives
matter
call for uh for community control of
policing
look what i support is the police
having the opportunity to deal with the
problems they face
and i'm not totally opposed to defunding
the police officers
as a matter of fact police local police
the only one defunding in his budget
calls for a 400 million dollar cut in
local law enforcement assistance
they need more assistance they need when
they show up for a 9 11 call to have
someone with them as a psychologist or
psychiatrist
to keep them from having to use force
and be able to talk people down
we have to have community policing like
we had before where the officers get to
know the people
in the community that's when crime went
down
it didn't go up it went down and so we
have to be in this that's not what
they're talking about
chris that's not where that's talking
about defunding the police that is not
true
he doesn't have any law he has no
law enforcement that's not true almost
that's not look
all right who do you have name one group
that supports you name one
that came out here you seriously better
say something i think we have a group we
don't have time to do it
and i want to get to another subject
which is the issue of protests
in many cities that have turned violent
in portland oregon especially
more than a hundred straight days
which i think where you talk about
peaceful protests many of those turned
into riots
mr vice president nypd you say that
people who commit crimes should be held
accountable
the question i have though is as the
democratic nominee and earlier tonight
you said that you are the democratic
party right now
have you ever called the democratic
mayor of portland or the democratic
governor of oregon
and said hey you've got to stop this
bring in the national guard
do whatever it takes but you'd stop the
days and months of violence
in portland i don't hold public office
now
i am a former vice president i've made
it clear
i've made it clear in my public
statements that the violence should be
prosecuted
it should be prosecuted and anyone who
commits it but you've never called for
the people
excuse me sir you had never called for
the leaders
in portland and in oregon
national guard it's really terrible a
hundred days of rhymes
they can in fact take care of it if you
just stay out of the way
oh really here
and by the way you know his own former
spokesperson said
you know riots and chaos and violence
help us cause
that's what this is all about i don't
know who said that i do
who i think kellyanne conway i don't
think she said she said that
and so here's all right but here's the
point the point is that
that's what he is keeps trying to rile
everything he's hilarious he doesn't
want to calm things down
instead of going in and talking to
people and saying let's get everybody
together and figure out how to deal with
it
what's he do he just pours gasoline in
the fire yes
i personally love him every single
solitary okay and and to
board this button up this segment i'm
going to give you a minute to answer sir
you have repeatedly
would be over there'd
white supremacists and militia groups
and
to say that they need to stand down and
not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
there's as we've seen different
definitions
almost everything i see is from the left
wing not from the right
so what do you what do you what are you
saying i'm i'm willing to do anything i
want to see people then do it sir say it
do it say it with birds you want to call
them what do you want to call them give
me your name give me a white surprise
and write problems stand back and stand
by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about
antifa and the left because this is not
a right-wing problem
this is a left-handed direction this is
a left-wing
white supremacist antifa is an idea not
an organization
is a danger all right gentlemen we're
now moving on to the trump
record when a president i'm going to ask
a question
when the president seeks a second term
it is generally a referendum on his
record
but vice president biden you'd like to
quote one of your dad's
sayings which is don't compare me to the
almighty
compare me to the alternative and in
this case sir you are
the alternative looking at both of your
records i'm going to ask each of you
why should voters elect you president
over your opponent
in this segment president trump you go
first two minutes
because there has never been an
administration or president
who has done more than i've done in a
period of three and a half years and
that's despite
the impeachment hoax and you saw what
happened today with hillary clinton
where it was a whole big con
job but despite going through all of
these things where i had to fight
both flanks and behind me and above
there has never been an administration
that's done what i've done the greatest
before covet came in the greatest
economy in history lowest employ
unemployment numbers everything was good
everything was going and by the way
there was unity going to happen people
were calling me for the first time in
years they were calling
and they were saying it's time maybe and
then what happened we got hit but now
we're building it back up again
a rebuilding of the military including
space force and all of the other things
a a fixing of the the va
which was a mess under him 308 000
people
died because they didn't have proper
health care he was a mess
and we now got a 91 approval rating
at the va our vets we take care of our
vets but we've rebuilt our military
the job that we've done and i'll tell
you something some people say maybe the
most i don't think there's anyone
at the end of the first term i'll have
approximately
300 federal judges and court of appeals
judges 300
and hopefully three great supreme court
judges
justices that is a record
the likes of which very few people and
you know one of the reasons i'll have so
many judges
because president obama and him left me
judges to fill when you leave office you
don't leave
any judges that's like you just don't do
that they left 128
openings and if i were a member of his
party
because they have a little different
philosophy i'd say if you left
us 128 openings you can't be a good
president
you can't be a good vice president but i
want to thank you because it gives us
almost it'll probably be above that
number by the end of this term
300 judges it's a record looking at both
your records
why should voters elect you president as
opposed to president trump you have two
minutes uninterrupted
under this president we become weaker
sicker
poorer more divided that's his more
violent
that's what he calls vice president we
inherited a recession
i was asked to fix it i did we left him
a booming
economy and he caused the recession with
regard to
being weaker the fact is that i've gone
head-to-head with putin
and made it clear to him we're not going
to take any of his stuff he's putin's
puppy he's still referring
mr president your campaign agreed to
both sides would get two minute answers
uninterrupted well your
your side agreed to it and why don't you
observe what your campaign agreed to as
a ground rule okay sir he never keeps
his words
no no no no i'm not actually that was a
rhetorical question
can you go back
you in the home you got less you're in
more trouble than you were before
in terms of being more violent when we
were in office there were 15 percent
less violence in america than there is
today he's president united states he
wrote this script on his
watch this is actually with regard to
more divided the nation
can't stay divided we can't be this way
and speaking of my son the way you talk
about the military
the way you talk about them being losers
and being
and and and just being suckers my son
say something was in iraq he spent a
year there
he got he brought the bronze star he got
the conspicuous service medal
he was not a loser he was a patriot
and the people left behind there were
heroes really and i resent you talking
about
are you talking about i'm talking about
my son beau biden you're talking i don't
know
i don't know i know hunter got thrown
out of the military
he was thrown out dishonorably
discharged that's not true
cocaine news and he didn't have a job
until you became vice president
what do you mean he made a fortune in
ukraine in china
in moscow
we've already been through this i think
the american people would rather hear
about more substantial
subjects well you know as the moderator
sir i'm going to make a reality
romney on that committee said it wasn't
worth taxpayers money that reporters
written for political reasons you know
i'd like to talk about climate change so
would i okay
a raging night okay i've got a whole
bunch of prepared information on that
displaced hundreds of thousands of
people
when state officials there blame the
fires on climate change mr president you
said i don't think
the science knows over your four years
you have pulled the us out of the paris
climate accord
you have rolled back a number of obama
environmental
records what do you believe about the
science of climate change the biggest
issue what will you do in the next four
years to confront it
i want crystal clean water and air i
want
beautiful clean air we have now the
lowest carbon if you look at
our numbers right now we are doing
phenomenally
but i haven't destroyed our businesses
our businesses aren't put out of
commission if you look at the paris
accord it was a disaster from our
standpoint and people
are actually very happy about what's
going on because our businesses are
doing well
as far as the fires are concerned you
need forest management
in addition to everything else the
forest floors are loaded up with
trees dead trees that are years old and
they're like tinder
and leaves and everything else you drop
a cigarette in there the whole forest
burns down
you've got to have forest management
what do you believe what do you believe
about the science of climate change sir
uh i believe that we have to do
everything we can to have
immaculate air immaculate water and do
whatever else we can that's right
yes i think to an extent yes but i also
think we have to do
better management of our forests every
year
i get the call california's burning
california is burning
if that was cleaned if that were if you
had forest management good
forest management and connection those
calls you know in europe they live their
forest cities they call forest cities
they maintain their forest they manage
their forests
i was with the head of a major country
it's a forest city
he said sir we have trees that are far
more they they ignite much easier than
california
there shouldn't be that problem i spoke
with the governor about it i'm getting
along very well with the governor
but i said you know at some point boy
you can't every year have you home
hundreds of thousands of acres of land
just burned to the ground
that's burning down because of a lack of
sir if you believe
in the science of climate change why
have you rolled back the obama
clean power plan which limited carbon
emissions in power plants why have you
relaxed cause it was driving energy
prices through the sky why have you
relaxed fuel
economy standards that are going to
create more pollution from
much cars expensive and it's a much
safer car and you're talking about a
tiny difference and then what would
happen
because of the cost of the car you would
have at least
double and triple the number of cars
purchased we have the old slugs out
there that are 10 12 years
old if you did that the car would be
safer it would be much cheaper but
california they've simply no but it
would take a lot of cars off the market
because people would be able to afford a
car
now so and by the way we're going to see
how that turns out
but a lot of people agree with me many
people the car has gotten so expensive
because they have computers all over the
place
for an extra little bit okay of gasoline
and i'm okay with electric cars
i'm because i've given big incentives
for electric cars
it's just crazy vice president biden i'd
like you to respond
to the president's climate change record
but i also want to ask you
about a concern you proposed two
trillion dollars in green
jobs you talked about new limits not
abolishing but new limits on fracking
ending the use of fossil fuels to
generate electricity by 2035
and zero net emission of greenhouse
gases by 2050
the president says a lot of these things
would tank the economy and cost millions
of jobs he's absolutely wrong
number one number two if in fact when
our during our administration the
recovery act i was able to i was in
charge able to bring down the cost
of renewables beautiful insomnia then or
as cheap as
cold gosh nobody's going to build
another
sleep uh basketball tonight or what's
making
and make sure that they in fact are
weatherized in a way that in fact
they'll emit significantly less gas and
oil because they heat more of them
there's so many things
i'm telling you
the paris accord i will join the paris
accord because with us
[Laughter]
more carbon
stop stop tearing down
the forest and if you don't then you're
going to have significant
economic consequences what about the
argument the president
basically says that you have to balance
environmental interests and economic
interests and he's drawn his line you
need to hook him up
for example make sure that he wants to
make sure that methane is not a problem
we can
you you can now emit more medicine the
longest trump's been quiet three
and it's not 2 billion or 20 billion as
you said
it's 100 trillion dollars i'm talking
about they want to rip down
and rebuild the buildings
you know that's not true either right
this is a this is a 100 trillion
that's more money than our country could
make in 100 years if we're not the case
let me let
me let me strictly because i actually
wait a minute sir i actually
have studied your plan and it includes
upgrading four million buildings
weatherizing two million hounds over
four years
building one and a half million energy
efficient homes
so the question becomes president is
saying i
think some people who support the
president would say that sounds
like it's going to cost a lot of money
and hurt the economy what it's going to
do it's going to create
thousands and millions of jobs good
paying jobs
sir
the fact is it's going to create
millions of goods you have to change it
really quickly
and these taxes create hundreds of jobs
weatherize what she wants to
get rid of it it's going to make the
economy much safer look how much we're
paying now
to deal with the hurricanes with the
deal with by the way he has an answer
for hurricanes he said
maybe we should drop a nuclear weapon on
them they may i never said that
he did she made it up uh and here's the
deal the makeup
we are going to be in a position where
we can create
hard hard good jobs by making sure the
environment
is clean and we all are in better shape
we spend
billions of dollars now billions of
dollars
on floods hurricanes rising seas
we're in real trouble look what's
happening just in the midwest with these
storms that come through and wipe out
entire sections and counties
in iowa they didn't happen before
they're because of global
warming we make up 15 of the world's
problems we in fact but the rest of it
we've got to get them to come along
that's what we have to get back
into back into the paris accord
all right gentlemen wait a minute chris
so why didn't he do it for 47 years
why didn't you get the world china sends
up real dirt into the air russia does
india does they all do we're supposed to
be good and by the way
he made a couple of statements the green
new deal is a hundred trillion dollars
that is not
my plan that's green well we want to
rebuild everything
my plan i want to rebuild anything
he made a statement about the military
he said i said something about the
military
he and his friends made it up and then
they went with it i never said it okay
that is vice president
little trouble myself but uh and about
the economy
and about this question of what it's
going to cost the the economy
i mean the green new deal and the idea
of what what your environmental changes
will do the green new deal will pay for
itself as we move forward
we're not going to build plants that in
fact are great polluting plants are you
going to build a brand new deal
pardon me do you support no i don't
support the agreement don't
oh well that's a big statement i support
you
that i put forward okay the biden clan
which is different than what he
calls the radical green new deal all
right gentlemen final segment
election integrity as we meet tonight
millions of americans
are receiving mail-in ballots or going
to vote early
how confident should we be that this
will be a fair election
and what are you prepared to do over the
next five
plus weeks because it'll not only be to
election day but also
counting some ballots mail-in ballots
after election day
what are you prepared to do to reassure
the american people that the next
president
will be the legitimate winner of this
election
in this final segment mr vice president
you go first prepare to let people vote
they should go to iwillvote.com
decide how they're going to vote when
they're going to vote and what means
his own homeland security director and
as well as the fbi director says there
is no
evidence at all that mail and ballots
are a source of
of being manipulated or cheated they
said that
the fact is that there are going to be
millions of people because of covet
that are going to be voting by mail and
ballots like he does by the way
he sits behind the resolute desk and
sends his ballot to florida
number one number two we're going to
make sure that those people who
want to vote in person are able to vote
make sure they can socially distance the
polls are open on time
and their polls stay open until the
votes are counted and this is all about
trying to dissuade people from voting
because he's trying to
is
and in terms of whether or not when the
votes are counted
they're going to
it's going to be all over he's going to
go he can't sound like somebody
sometimes
the voice has gotten higher throughout
just
make sure you understand you have it in
my
control determine what this country's
going to look like the next four years
mr president two minutes so when i
listened to joe
talking about a transition yeah there's
been no transition from when i won i won
that election
and if you look at crooked hillary
clinton if you look at all of the
different people
there was no transition because they
came after me trying to do a coup
they came after me spying on my campaign
they started from the day i won and even
before i won from the day i came down
the escalator
with our first lady they were a disaster
they were a disgrace to our country
and we've caught them we've caught them
all we've got it all on tape we've
caught them all and by the way you gave
the idea for the logan act against
general flynn
you better take a look at that because
we caught you in a sense and
president obama was sitting in the
office he knew about it too so don't
tell me about a free transition
as far as the ballots are concerned
a solicited ballot okay
solicit it is okay you're so listening
you're asking they send it back you send
it back
i did that if you have an unsolicited
they're sending millions of ballots all
over the country
there's fraud they found them in creeks
they found some with the name trump just
happened to have the name trump
just the other day in a waste paper
basket they're being sent all over the
place
they sent two in a democrat area they
sent out a thousand ballots everybody
got two ballots
this is going to be a fraud like you've
never seen the other thing
it's nice on november 3rd you're
watching and you see who won the
election
and i think we're going to do well
because people are really happy with the
job we've done
but you know what we won't know we might
not know for months
because these ballots are going to be
all over take a look at what happened in
manhattan take a look at what happened
in
new jersey take a look at what happened
in virginia and other places
they're not losing two percent one
percent which by the way is too much an
election could be one or lost with that
they're losing 30 and 40 percent it's a
fraud
and it's a shame and can you imagine
where they say
uh you have to have your ballot in by
november 10th
when it comes to november 10 that means
that's seven days
after the election
you're going to be able to continue you
have been charging for months that
mail-in balloting
is going to be a disaster are you saying
we're already working with that it's
going to lead to fraud
but in 2018 in the last election 31
million people
voted voting that was
a quarter more than a quarter of all the
voters that year cast their ballots by
mail
now that millions of mail-in ballots
have gone out
what are you going to do about it and
are you counting on the supreme court
including a justice barrett to settle
any dispute yeah i think i'm counting on
them to look at the ballots definitely i
don't think well i hope we don't need
them
in terms of the election itself but for
the ballots i think so
because what's happening is incredible i
just heard i read today where
at least one percent of the ballots for
were invalidated they they take them we
don't like them we don't like them they
throw them out
if there are millions of ballots going
on what you do is you go and vote you do
a solicited ballot no no that's okay i
know where are you going
i'm asking you about the fact that
millions of people you go and vote
you go and vote like they think like
they used to video
millions of people you either do chris a
solicited ballot where you're sending it
into sending
this is a horrible thing for our country
this is not
is no this is not going to end well
okay this is not going to vice president
obama live straight in fact
for the last decade or more five
including two republican states
and you don't have to solicit the ballot
it's sent to you
it's sent to your home what we're saying
is they're saying is that has to be a
postmark
by the time just by election day if it
doesn't get in until the
seventh eighth grade it still should be
counted
he's just afraid of counting the votes
because you're wrong
i want to continue with you on this vice
president
sometimes hundreds of thousands of
ballots are thrown out because they
have not been properly filled out or
there is some other irregularity or they
must be free
the deadline so the question i have is
are you concerned
that the supreme court with a justice
barrett will settle any dispute
i am concerned that any court would
settle this because here's the deal
when you when you file when you get a
ballot
and you fill it out you're supposed to
have an affidavit if you didn't know you
have
someone say that this is me you should
be able to if in fact you can verify
that you
when the before the ballot is thrown out
that's sufficient to be able to count
the ballot
because someone made a mistake and not
dotting the correct guy who they vote
testify
they await say who they voted for say
it's you
that is totally legitimate all right
you know it can't be done you know it
can't and already all right
in eight states election workers are
prohibited
currently by law eight states from even
beginning to process
ballots even take them out of the
envelope
until we find out who the the new
president is so i
first for you sir finally for the for
the vice president i hope neither of you
will interrupt the other
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in
any civil unrest and will you pledge
tonight that you will not declare
victory
until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you for watching
my supporters to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen
i am urging them to do it as you know
today there was a big problem in
philadelphia they went in to watch they
were
called poll watchers a very safe very
nice thing they were thrown out they
weren't allowed to watch
you know why because bad things happen
in philadelphia bad things
and i am urging i am urging my people i
hope it's going to be a fair election if
it's a fair election
i am 100 on board but if i see tens of
thousands of ballots being manipulated
i can't go along with that and i'll tell
you what is that from a common sense
does that mean you're telling
your people it means you have a
fraudulent election you're sending out
80 million
hey they found ballots in a waste paper
basket
three days ago and they all had the name
military ballots they were military
they all had the name trump on them vice
president i think that's good
vice president biden final question for
you will you urge your supporters to
stay calm
while the vote is counted and will you
pledge not to declare victory until the
election is
certified yes and here's the deal with
the encounter
some of these ballots in some states
can't even be opened until election day
and if there's thousands of ballots
going to take time to do it and by the
way
our like somebody i'm trying military
say like balance
first cartoon character voice i'm being
serious and that's
and that's what's happened going to
happen why was it all perceived
we're not talking about the entire
country of people it's on us
that somehow it's a fraudulent process
it's already been established
take a look at caroline's race
go ahead he has no idea what he's
talking about here's the deal
the fact is i will accept it and here's
the deal why
and then joe because of the deal once
the winner is declared after all
all the ballots are counted all the
votes are counted that'll be here
that'll be the end of like oh okay and
if it's me in fact fine if
if it's not me i'll support the other
job and i'll be a president not just for
the
democrats i'll be a president for
democrats and republicans
and this guy i want to say gentlemen
would you say that's the end of it this
is the end of this debate this ballot
count
we're going to leave it there uh to be
continued
as in more debates as we go on that's it
that's the end
i'm out of here man president biden it's
been an interesting hour and a half i
want to thank you both
for participating in the first of three
debates that you have agreed to
engage we want to thank case western
reserve university
and the cleveland clinic for hosting
this event
one week from tomorrow october 7th at
the university of utah
two vice presidential nominees vice
president mike pence
all right so if you're listening to this
guys what are you thinking about just so
everybody knows we had some kind of a
glitch something happened here where we
lost you on the first time we were all
the way up to five six thousand people
that were watching and then uh our buddy
there one of our guys was
sliding around and the cable came out
but we're together now so i got my notes
i want to hear from you guys who
surprised you now here's the thing if
i'm asking i'm actually curious because
a lot of you guys are saying funny
things
if you're a trump supporter and you know
you're a trump guy
so i know you're going to say oh i love
trump he crushed it
did bite and surprise you a little bit
and if you're a biting person you cannot
stand trump
was there any time where you were like
well biden doesn't look good trump was
kind of looking good here so i don't
want you to take the lead what were
somebody i'm going first both of them
let me wake up a little bit
let me slap myself both of them i got
some points i made i'm curious to know
what you think about it
so like in fights they they they go
round by round
honestly look at his eyes i don't know
if the camera can you zoom in on adam's
eyes
how many drinks have you had how many
drinks actually honestly half of that
i've had i've had a stiff cocktail i got
advising here for the red eyes adam
i've never seen you this time i've been
around you at 9 41 many times
i've never seen you get out of your mind
so tell us what what what the hell jack
if you take away the last half hour of
the debate
we'll talk about first hour then we'll
get the last half hour was very um
again buy these expectations very low
half of the people here literally said
they didn't think he was going to show
up
he showed up he showed off some stuff he
was bobbing and weaving
we got our colombian guy that might
kicked out of the country who knows
um he held his own he made some points
he made some counterpoints
there's a few things number one trump is
a seventh grader maybe a fifth grader
he cannot shut his mouth biden
on a handful of points he got shut down
when trump said name one name one police
organization that supports you
if i knew a police organization that
should that would support me
bro i'm shouting that from the rooftops
he just looked down
didn't say nothing you know you got it
not good
that that was not good on body's part
however other than being boring
do you think do you think he has
dementia
did he did he give her off any dementia
i don't know if i got that feeling at
all no no but that's
what the no i don't think i got that the
biden haters have been saying
i think the biden haters are also saying
that he had a uh earpiece in or maybe he
takes pbs to get some energy maybe he's
doing some trt
some steroids to get some energy i
honestly think they need to do something
with makeup like
richard nixon when he came out on the
first debate with john f kennedy on
national television at four o'clock
shaving
that to face john f kennedy came out he
was perfectly tanned looking good
shaved took he slept a ton that night
before to be very well rested
they need to do something with the
makeup on the next one they need to take
that seriously it's a camera it's a tv
you gotta do it you have that problem on
the first one even though
you even allow that to happen you know
you're a professional like i
we we at least we i watch you prepare
right
you know you got the makeup you do stuff
you've been on tv your entire life
we're amateurs this is not what we do
for a living you've been doing this
entire life
you know how to get yourself prepared
what is that i mean just to look along
what do you think about that
was the lighting was the lack of makeup
i mean that's what one thing you can
control
in a debate you can't control very much
but you can control how your candidate
looks and that should have been tested
that i should have been prepared for you
know
i think biden would have been such a
better candidate 30 or 40 years ago you
know
when he had a little bit more energy the
left is propping him up to be their guy
right now and it's just not working i'll
make a couple points
and i don't want to make a sports
analogy but in the nfl what teams do is
they script their first 25 plays
so they go all week in practice knowing
what their first 25 plays are going to
be
that's what biden did at the beginning
of this debate that's why he was so
strong
he was ready he knew what the questions
were he was prepared
he came out and surprised me he had a
little bit more fire and he sounded
you know like cohesive um number two i
got tired of the turning to the camera
thing i think that works once or twice
talking to the american people i'll buy
that once or twice but then i think it's
forced
interesting and that's how i felt it was
after a while that was clearly a
strategy of his
number three tomorrow the media i can
predict it right now
trump's a bully that's all they're going
to talk about but you know what
trump made good ballot points as a
president to rebut some of the things
that biden was saying and here's my
final point i was scared
of biden becoming president before this
debate now i'm petrified
okay so that's how i feel after watching
him
because i i just his his philosophies
his issues the things he stands for i
don't think he can think straight
i don't think he's of i don't think he's
making decisions on his own
you cannot say that trump isn't his own
person probably tells a bunch of people
every day to screw you
you know you know he does what he wants
when he wants you just don't get that
vibe
from biden and it's too important what's
going on in the country right now
to rely on someone that doesn't have a
backbone or some real legitimate plans
for what he wants to do he's a puppet
and it just is a fact and it just kind
of came across tonight in this debate
jarrah oh man
um you know i think that
i was very surprised at how articulate
biden was
i mean he had a few you know glitches in
the force there
um but it makes me wonder is somebody
communicating with him i'm wondering
like what in the houston astros is going
on
over here you know what i mean like how
did he come out how did he come out this
strong
okay um i was disappointed that they
didn't spend more time
on uh the supreme court nominee i think
that the constant interruptions between
the both of them but more so on trump's
part
i think that's almost intentional to dis
you know to to keep us away from the key
issues
um it might surprise some of the viewers
who think that
you know women need to support women
just because we both have vaginas
that i'm not really sold on barrett
i don't think that she's a
constitutional judge
um i don't uh i've done some research on
her and honestly
i've been disappointed i wish they would
have spent a little more time on this
whole like
psychiatrist going out with law
enforcement they
these two people have no idea they think
they know
but they have no idea what law
enforcement deals with on a daily basis
and until they get their butts in a cop
car
and they go out and they deal with
people high on pcp
people trying to stab their boyfriends
and wives and
people beating their kids until they're
dealing with
the issues that law enforcement deals
with until they see it with their own
eyes and spend a lot of time
doing it they are never going to
understand the correlation
between law enforcement and the
communities especially
the situations that we're dealing with
now in society i would like to see
more humility from trump trump did not
do
all of the things that he did in his
administration he needs to start giving
more credit
to his administration and stop saying i
i i that's fair
although and now we've talked about the
the uh the interruptions and
i feel like a lot of them were to knock
biting off this game but i also thought
that the majority
kind of leaned to for me the way i felt
about it was was it leaned a little bit
more towards wait a second that's
[ __ ]
you know what i mean that's that's
that's fair i'm passionate about this
subject and this is why i'm stopping you
and let's face it i mean you know uh you
know trump doesn't
he doesn't mind interrupting anyway so
you know at that point why not jump in
i thought that biden again like
everybody else i mean he started off
strong i didn't expect much
um and he didn't deliver much i mean
just because he had a
good couple of first minutes i mean it's
like you know i don't think he's going
to steal anything there you know
he would have been better off stealing
the last 10 minutes in the first 10
minutes you know what i mean so
i you know i uh i i'm horrified of
the idea of biden becoming president
based on what i heard too
i mean he did dodge some things when we
were talking law enforcement yeah but
you know what i mean and that kind of
made me work
we're talking the big green deal and all
that other stuff i mean that makes me
worried especially after that aoc
comment that we can push
biden a certain direction as she was
quoted saying well
i'll tell you a couple things so so one
if you're watching this you're enjoying
this put it put a thumbs up and uh click
on the subscribe button on the alert
button
but let's go back to a couple things he
talked about so number one
trump said namely one law enforcement
group that supports you he couldn't do
it
game over there okay just so you know
that game over there
their campaign has to immediately
go beg one law enforcement group in the
next week to come out
to say we support them somebody's got to
do it tomorrow so if i'm part of biden's
campaign i'm sitting there saying dude
call somebody that we need a favor from
who's the sheriff who's one county we
need
i don't care who it is call wisconsin
call minnesota call somebody somebody's
got to say
we support bike that's number one
priority and it's got to be from five
different places tomorrow it's a
catastrophe
for that to be taking place and then
they need to make a nice viral video to
say
i'm with the sheriff we support so
that's number one i agree if that
doesn't happen it's gonna be a big
problem here because
uh believe it or not what barclay said
the other day says this whole thing
about defunding the police you have no
clue what the hell you're talking about
black people need more cops because
black neighborhoods need more cops
barkley said this the other shaq
agreed with them so that's one thing
with him that's a problem right there
number two and trump talked about the
fact that
you leave 128 judges for me to pick what
the hell are you doing
are you out of your freaking mind so for
me if i'm a democrat i'm sitting there
saying
why did you guys leave 128 judges are
you out of your mind
you talk about roe versus weight you
cannot leave these many judges free
of course he's going to replace some
record-breaking 300 judges he's got two
of them now
he's going to do his third supreme court
justice first president to do this since
uh reagan on first term in three three
different supreme courts you know i mean
that's insane for him to be able to do
that so that's that part the other part
biden's zinger it is what it is and you
are what you are
yes tomorrow see that on the cover of
new york times
it is i'm just telling you marketing
standpoint it is what it is
you are who you are it is what it is you
are that's problem i'm not checked
twitter i guarantee you that's been
tweeted out
by hundreds of thousands of people it is
what it is you are who you are so that's
that part
good form with that one it was a good
comment that was written when he's
i just shut up i don't know if i'm
comfortable with that
i'm just telling you that i'm not
comfortable i'll just shut up now if
it's ever gonna be okay to say uh just
shut up it's gonna be against trump
because trump said every single thing
but if it's against a bush i don't think
that would have worked i think if it's
against senior
i don't think it's gonna work if it's
against him it's going to work because
trump's
trump said a lot of other things i'll
just shut up it's not going to be the
biggest one so that part's going to be
kind of
you know canceling each other out the
other comment when he said antifa
is not uh is an idea not an organization
that was one of the scariest comments
this guy could have made
and breitbart's going to run with that
tomorrow fox is going to run with that
right now they're writing daily wires
running with that
they're all over the place writing about
antifa is not an idea so they're going
to take the antifa idea
and they're going to show every single
thing about the organization that they
stand for
that's not going to be good from biden's
camp on where he's at the other one
where he said under this administration
would become weaker sacred violent
and more divided to the average voter
that's going to resonate with not to the
person that's going to go out there and
study and see what's actually going on
the fact that you know the more riots
and protesting you
endorse behind closed doors it's better
for democrats the more there is rights
the more they can say
look what happened under a trump organ
administration look how many rights
there are look how many
statistically democrats write more than
republicans right that's just
statistically what happens
but it favors them so that statement of
saying under this administration
we become weaker sicker more violent and
more divided
that was good whoever wrote that form
that whole bit that he wrote the entire
entire thing by the way he never looked
up he read the entire thing which means
he didn't write it
somebody wrote it from kudos for the
person that wrote the form and then a
couple things kai if you want to pull
this
up when he says you said stupid uh clap
you stupid bastards he says i never said
that you
ca he can't stop he can't say things
like that can you pull up the video
where he says you stupid bastards watch
this
we're just waiting for them to get it on
the camera do we have it so they can see
it
ready okay let's take a look
watch this
[Music]
here's the other one go to usa today
actually just type in this is what i
typed in online
for some people to see this i typed in
online
i typed in was hunter biden dishonorable
discharge just type in was
hunter biden dishonorable discharge i
was in the military a lot of people got
dishonorable discharge
one of the guys in our barracks got
caught with cocaine dishonorable
discharge
you got a 187 you know go to uh uh
uh uh yeah click on the usa today right
there
by this is 2014 by the way so it's not
like this was just written yesterday in
biden was a vp ty we don't want ads
oh buddy this continue to cite
okay it keeps popping up yeah can we do
anything about it okay i'll read it to
you i'll read it to you since we can't
do nothing about it it's a new computer
biden's son fails drug test is
discharged from the navy
written by usa today okay and it tells
you the story of what happened there
that joe you know
you know the younger son failed the drug
test for cocaine
a month after his commissioning last
year into the navy reserve and was
discharged
so that's a factual statement to be made
and there's more stories to go there
but the biggest thing is let's set those
stories aside remember we're dealing
with ten percent we're not dealing with
forty two percent forty four percent or
uh the four percent the ten percent
right now is watching okay
the ten percent right now is watching so
imagine i
am somebody who doesn't read politics
you are somebody who doesn't read the
usa today
you are somebody that doesn't watch fox
or cnn you are guys we can't hear you
you are somebody that doesn't follow any
of this stuff right you don't follow any
of this stuff you're just a regular
person that's working
hoping that you're going to be kind of
going back about your business just kind
of watching this whole thing taking
place
i'm i am honestly i'm telling you right
now if you guys try to tell me let's do
part two of this debate i'm not open to
it i'm telling you i'm not open to it
i'm not going to watch this thing like
this i can't i can't watch this on a 1.0
speed
i wish i could watch this on a 2.0 speed
you want me to sit through this again on
a second time
you knocked out half the time you were
bored out of your i'm being so
serious i'm almost sitting in my mind
ticked off that we
even bit this thing here right now fine
it's a great idea that has got to be the
most
boring debate i've seen i like a good
fight
you got this whole thing when you watch
sports right what do you like about
sports
nuggets against clippers love that
series right you're watching and saying
this is sick
this is what i'm talking about right you
watch a fight
allegiance norton ali against
frazier ali these are good fights
have you ever seen a boring fight what
do you want to do at the end of a boring
fight
do something you are you are pissed off
that you spend money you are pissed off
you waste the time
you are pissed off you coordinate the
whole thing this may be
the most boring most under
you know overly promoted debate i've
ever seen in my life i've never been
more bored of a debate than this one
here today well it's a testimony that he
just can't bring
what else is i think it's just yeah i
mean what
for these guys for the next one you know
is biden just gonna rely on marketing
slogans you know trump's his worst enemy
he's gonna have to peel back
on some of those interruptions because
it doesn't help him and i think one
final thought i have
uh trump set the tone that hunter biden
is gonna be an album uh
uh a problem for joe biden right
especially when he find out lied about
him
i mean he hammered him hard on hunter on
his son
like laying the groundwork that there's
some things out there that's gonna come
out so
i don't know i'm sure trump doesn't get
about it but to me if biden gets elected
you know what are i think that we're
going to implode internally and
externally like where are our foreign
relations going to go
i mean countries are going to eat this
guy alive governors
are going to eat this guy alive he has
no he i mean he has no presence to him
that instills any kind of authority to
me you worried about other countries not
respecting america you're saying
yeah i mean the polls are pretty
lopsided where other countries respected
obama
way more than they do trump like them
probably i'm just saying
i can i can see that but what i i'm not
necessarily talking about respect
i'm talking about is he going to be able
to get anything done
is he going to get railroaded in trade
deals and foreign
i think both of them are very
weak candidates the like biden is a very
weak candidate
agreed yeah probably the worst
democratic candidate we've seen
in 40 years yeah yeah he's the favorite
he's the favorite we covered that in the
tail of the tape he's winning in the
polls right now
give this to him that's how bad that's a
pillow because thank you yeah that's how
bad that's how bad of a candidate trump
is
don't forget that okay that also could
be some skew polling
i mean that's what they said before
twenty there's or there could be some
accurate pulling well the pol the
pollings
said that hillary was gonna win the
hillary was winning until
comey dropped the bomb two weeks before
the election
okay let's not forget she won the
popular vote did she not but that
doesn't matter
popular vote doesn't matter anymore it
never did since
popular world doesn't get we don't
people care at all were you born in
america is that another set of fights
the electoral college obviously
is the the name of the game here but she
won by more than
four million votes if you're not going
to count all the quote-unquote illegal
votes
i'm just saying that's how bad of a
candidate trump is is that he's losing
in the polls right now
to sleepy joe biden adam i did it i did
a question the other day i said
i asked the question i said who's ever
had
a pollster approach them okay i ask you
have you had anybody approach you and
tell you
who you're voting for have i ever had a
poster yes
ever no yes by the election yes who what
was it local or presidential
was it local was it like a mayor was it
like a congress senator or was it a
presidential household inside of a
polling station
outside of a polling station yeah in the
house exit poll is what you're saying
exit poll okay oh no no no no i'm
talking like imagine like a september
does anybody come up to you telling you
who you're voting for come up to me
where
anywhere buddy have you ever pulled for
anything i'm talking to strangers bro
get out of my face dude
but what i'm trying to tell you is if
you believe in poles
outside of pew research pew or rasmussen
and there's one month
if it's gallop you right i trust i'll
i'll take those three
anything else fox news paul nope uh
siena paul
no msnbc po no i i watched billboard the
other day
pilmer said the best thing he says you
know how i see paul's i said he's like i
i think these guys kind of sit there and
say yeah
what do you think you know who do you
think he's gonna you know why i think
he's got a 59
less i agree with gilbert i think he's
got a point i think there's a bunch of
guys are sitting in the room and they
just say yeah i think i think biden's
got the lead right now 59
do you realize how off they were in
2016.
let me tell you 2016 i'm on the phone
with my friend tom
till three o'clock in the morning we
can't believe what happened
i mean 2016 was like nobody thought this
was going to take place
there's a video that got a few hundred
million views it was just the rea
it always shows up the reaction of
people when trump got elected
so for you to say anything about polls
it's just not going to be but
one of the guys needs to go take a nap
right now biden needs to go take a nap
that you said you agree with how how
many
how many how many interviews do you
think trump can do right now how many
interviews thinking inviting can do
right now there's no question trump has
more energy though
but here's a question for you okay if
you're gonna have
somebody to be the ceo of a company what
what is something you need to be the ceo
of the company
you need to be tough you need to not be
afraid of the competitors
you need to make sure your biggest
enemies kind of don't like you
okay you you can't have china around a
north korea like you
and you need to be able to last a long
time this is a game of lasting
this is where stamina matters this is
when endurance matters
forget about all the other stuff i don't
care how big your resume is
i don't think that guy's being able to
be going to be able to last and have the
stamina to be a president no doubt
the the guy does not have stamina then
for sure that means the concept
let's let's flip the other side don't
you also need honesty
can't you not be a pathological liar
disappointed
is racism not a thing do you think is
the fact that you're
a complete un empathetic person
not matter sure there's countless ceos
that have tons of energy that have
complete
ra ra cis boom bob but they're piece of
shits
okay and their companies suffer for it
how many ceos do you know that are have
super energy but they run their
companies into the ground
what's your point with that my point is
just because you have energy does it
make you a great leader
what's your point with that though when
you're saying something like that how
many companies has this guy built
how many bills how many times have you
stayed at the trump hotel how many times
you go see his brands everywhere so
let's just have uh
how many times do 15 seasons of a
printer let me put
let's talk about that say if bill gates
runs if a bill gates goes against biden
i you better believe i'm going gays i go
gates too the reason for this is he has
the energy to be able to think this kind
of stuff
you're not gonna sit there and think
about a guy like that can last what are
you talking about this is not even about
politics at this point of the game
this is about some and you're talking
about empathy you think china's got
empathy for you
i'm sorry buddy if we get into the
streets and somebody wants to attack me
i don't give a [ __ ] if you have empathy
i give a [ __ ] if i'm safe i'm not hoping
you have some empathy
i'm hoping you protect my ass if i'm in
war
and i'm getting attacked i don't sit in
the bunker and say hey
uh private jones before i go out there
can i get a hug bro cause i need
something
all i'm thinking about is you better
have my six when i go there seriously
dude pat you need a hug
could possibly be moved tonight don't
you think they're watching this and
feeling a little bit more secure
listening to trump about law and order
about
having a track record about lower taxes
watching his performance tonight i think
if it's a little part in the middle that
tiny little fringe
i think trump came out on behalf of
someone who has voted democrat
for the majority of his life nobody in
the democratic party is
excited about joe biden we're not
fist-bumping saying
yo joe got this thing y'all we
then how yeah he get there because to me
and everyone else could become far more
more qualified and better candidates
i think is better than him and i don't
even like her
had four percent of the polls if that
okay i think she's awful
oh i mean well you might get a big taste
of her yeah
i'm not a kamala fan and you know as far
as as far as being liked i mean in
in and i don't know i guess it's a
machiavellian type thing it's it's being
feared
and being loved and and you know he's
not a lovable guy and i get that
you know and as far as [ __ ] talk about
trump you know yeah i mean to some
people he's just not
a lovable guy is he feared for sure fear
can draw that
respect that we need to make our our
place in the world again i mean
we don't have it we haven't had it a
long time and i kind of think he's he's
doing
um you know he's he's making these new
deals what is he feared by
north korea north korea who they're
writing letters to one another you think
that
he fears them okay who else yeah i mean
yeah i mean i i
i don't know who else fears trump i
think i think iran
okay for sure right yeah i mean you know
doesn't want to become president no way
no oh god no yeah if china feared him
would they have released the virus to
the
to the world if they feared that's a big
statement
that i mean that's a question at the
same time right
you don't you don't think that biden is
here right now because he's easy to
control
did biden not win the nominee fair and
square do you not
but do you not think he won the
nomination because he's easy to control
by the dnc but who the voters put
the voters voted for him so you can say
that he was controlled
by whoever you want people voted for him
well the dnc also probably forced some
candidates to drop out
to get out of the out of the running in
the primaries
bachmann or oh bachmann well i mean
that's who was going to win the race
clearly they made a deal or who's the
the congressman from minnesota do you
think about michelle bachman from
seven years ago no i'm talking about the
congresswoman for after klobuchar
klobuchar
she had a chance they're like listen
clover shark go take a clover shark get
out of here buddy
like she's she's not going anywhere
whether you like him or not i'm not a
huge bite and supporter
he wanted fair and square he won this he
won the nominee
he won the nomination all right let's
finish this who won tonight who won
tonight
give us give us a holy football score
how many rounds give us a football score
football score
give us a football score i go first who
do you want to go first ladies first
go ahead girl who won the football score
uh i mean it's it's it's below 10. you
know i'm going 7-3 trump oh wow like a
touchdown game
because what would you say i say 31-14
trump although he had about six
turnovers okay he cocked up the ball a
lot
all right he was sloppy all right but he
look at the scoreboard at the end of the
game he kicked the ass
31 40. i don't think there's a lot of
touchdowns happening in this
go ahead buddy good i would say fourteen
three
four ten three field goal that's it
that's all he had
i think trump won uh 17-14 in overtime
all right in the fourth quarter in
overtime mine wasn't waking up i got
nine six
three points
what's the most boring football game
you've seen in your life
do you know like you bring your friends
over like you know what dude guys this
game is going to be sick
come on over everybody comes we got the
chips you got the drinks ready got the
music
family everything in his score is nine
to six you know
you go to a baseball game what do you
want to watch at a baseball game a home
run i saw i just saw two guys screaming
at each other
and uh who's the who's the moderator on
the second one
do we know as a second moderator on the
next one is it cooper's a decent
moderator
who's a second moderator
can we give a grade to chris wallace
how do you think chris wallace did hey
it's a tough challenge
i think he tries zero to ten okay zero
to ten he did a
a six point nine something like that to
seven point one i mean he tried
so i mean he's looking up at these guys
from the powerhouse he's railroading
them
i i mean i would actually split it in
two parts too i'd say that the first
half he
lost control completely and and he was
at a two
maybe he recovered at a seven okay you
both got sevens
pbd jarrah i don't
i don't really think he did a good job
at all i would give him like a four
i would give him like a really because
he was he basically was doing joe
biden's job for him
okay for a lot of the second half of the
debate and
he had he had no control now trump is a
hard person
to control so we have to give him that
but i don't i don't think he did a good
job as a moderator at all we need
somebody that's
you need a bully like trump to be
moderating this and i go joe rogan all
the way
totally agree he's gotta be like you
gotta have somebody that's just gonna
tell if the spotify
that's a good point a very good point
did this glimpse okay so what score you
give him you give him a score now four
four adam i'm going lower than you i'm
going to three and a half okay
at some point as the moderator yeah you
need to step in and say guys
although i think you're making it seem
like an easier job than it is that's
tough
you're dealing with two children over
here like that's what it felt like to me
like i taught second grade for a year
and a half i can actually see you
when i was doing comedy at night telling
jokes by day were you certified as a
teacher
teaching by by day yeah certified
substitute teacher
i was a substitute and then the the
substitute got sick and i filled in for
the rest of the year
point is when you have two little kids
interrupting each other
it just at some point you got to say the
two of you are going to go into your
corner
and if you say another word you're going
to be kicked out of class at some point
you need to step in
like nerd alert chris wallace over here
is like excuse me uh excuse me um
well may i please excuse me mr president
uh shut the [ __ ] up and listen to me
okay that's what he needed
his roommate was the teacher and
couldn't go so he just made this based
on a true story
based on a true story anyway trump was
and this is
i mean you asked initially what my
problem was what like the tax attacks
on the list of things that the democrats
or liberals however you want to put
it are fed up with trump about it's not
the tax stuff
it's the fact that they that a a man
baby is running the country
whether you agree with his policies or
not it's the fact that he can't just sit
there and respect
a debate enough where he's like oh yeah
i'm sure yeah oh yeah right man
that is the thing that's limiting his
successes it's like if he didn't do that
and he was just just a racist
race-baiting you know massages
that'd be one thing but the fact that
he's a baby doing all that what did he
have
one instance of race-baiting misogyny
you know we could check
the record okay anyways chris wallace
three and a half how about
three and a half yes i say four in the
face of republicans
eight for democrats i think he
helped biden a lot uh a lot
and biden needed it and he helped out a
lot and
if there's a bonus being given on the
side he deserves a bonus he deserves a
bonus from the dnc
because i think he was this was two
against one uh and
and and i this was too young you never
once heard him jump in
for the other side but he did with trump
uh but on the other side i'll tell you
this as a whole like a total
you know i put him a five five and a
half score on how we do i don't think
it's an easy job
uh but i i do think these both guys
agreed to it i think trump jumped jumped
in way too much and he couldn't hold
himself
and trump almost came in like you know
guy who goes into a fight and just he
knows he's better than the other guy
like he can come in prepared at a level
five and he's still gonna beat the other
guy now there's boxers like that
that's what i felt with trump i think
trump just came in like i don't really
need to be prepared for this
i'm gonna beat this guy no matter what
because you're one-tenth of what hillary
was so
when you go against people like hillary
and your life and you face somebody like
this you're not really intimidated by
someone like this
and the problem becomes you don't
prepare as well i hope he prepares a
little bit more on the next one
uh i do think he won the debate 100 i
think he won the debate
but i think he's two nine to six but he
still won the debate i still think he
won the debate
uh uh with how this thing ended up so
anyways
final thoughts before we wrap up here uh
does this
really mean anything or a bunch of thing
can happen between now
and the last event and then the other
question is
was the story with the taxes is
everybody gonna forget about it tomorrow
because think about how many big stories
just happened cindy mccain
uh dwayne johnson uh ilhan omar
you got the uh tax thing that just came
out
you got all these other things that came
out in the last you got the uh
sec what do you call it uh supreme court
that's on the line there's a lot of
things that happen in one week
if the right marketing doesn't happen on
each side
if you don't know how to get the right
story out the media is going to be able
to control whatever story they want
now it's about which one of those
stories they take the lead with and
unfortunately i think this thing's going
to be forgotten very quickly yeah okay i
look at it like a ufc
card right this was like the third fight
before the
main event okay every there it's not
going to move the needle for either side
and we're going to forget about it very
quickly
it's a good warm-up for number two the
only one they're going to remember is
number three so
i i think the big question going in the
next one is trump going to learn to not
be his own worst enemy because he was
tonight
because he gave the media the ammunition
that they are looking for
to flip this as far as the narrative
tomorrow and that's what it's all going
to be about
how he was rude or he was a bully and
they're going to gloss over
you know how he basically crushed him
point for point
yeah i actually think it's going to be
it's going to be his to lose i mean if
he's going to be his own worst enemy and
it's going to you know i didn't think he
pushed the envelope too far
tonight and i was worried about it going
in thinking is he going to do something
offensive and you know if
it's going to go too far you know i
loved what he did he stopped short on
the beau biden thing and and
that began real specific he said hunter
biden so
i you know i i don't think this is going
to move anything i think you're right
maybe in the third i don't think any of
these things are going to are going to
really move anything i don't think
biden's really going to come out of his
shell at all
i'll be surprised if he does in two or
three i don't see much from biden
i think uh biden did a great job of
diffusing the fact that people are
saying that he's
um lost the step has dementia
he's not going to show up right but i
think he did a
very poor job of losing the sleepy joe
biden
moniker the guy put me to sleep i'll
blame it partially on my contacts
but also a little sleepy
so also blaming on jarrah she liquored
me up
straight up um but overall i think trump
she's a child but sometimes you know as
you guys say sometimes you need a child
to be
out there ruling the world uh because
you you know you want your enemies to
respect
the child joe not a good candidate
but again let's see what the polls have
to say
i'm i'm far more interested in you know
i think this was a complete [ __ ] show it
didn't impress me at all
and i'm far more interested to see what
the vice presidential debate
brings us next month i think isn't it
coming up in
october and i want to see uh
i want to see that i think that's going
to be a little bit more at least as
energy can be possible
i think they both have a little bit more
you know when we were in you know when
we when we did ltc class and we talked
about
the ego state theory right the parent
adult and child ego state
i think that that pence and harris have
a little bit
more ability to stay in the adult ego
state with each other than this
than this circus i don't think that's
great
i actually don't disagree so i think
that maybe i think that maybe
some of the issues that we were wanting
to spend more time on
might get tackled on october 7th versus
what we saw tonight i think we're going
to see how extreme harris is
number one and i don't think pence will
be drawn into any of those personal
battles he's
pretty stoic you know he's got a little
he's pretty easy
to him yeah yeah absolutely so i'm just
i'm gonna think i'm a little more
interested in that
in that then this was this was a
disappointment
for me okay so my sister said adam is
even sitting on the left of the stage
that was on purpose tigran our buddy
said biden got a safety
trump won three two
noel said i need a drink this is one of
the worst debates he's ever seen and my
dad
asked me what do you think i said i'm
falling asleep and uh
you know so are a lot of other people
anyways gang if you're watching this if
you enjoyed this format let us know
comment below if you want to see us do
today
if you want to see it again click on the
subscribe button click on the thumbs up
comment below uh uh we'll see if we're
going to do this again it'll be
mainly on your reaction if you enjoyed
it we may consider again if not we won't
do it again
but uh having said that uh rapatoni
tom jarrah adam this was a blast
i think uh uh i think you took a break
to go to the bathroom i don't know if
you did go to did he go to the bathroom
or no
i think you didn't cheese
they have to go to the bathroom after
eating cheese i'm good but did you take
a break to go to the bathroom
be honest nice try wait a minute i
washed my hands but did you go
do anything wash my hands i'm gonna wash
my hands it took you six minutes to wash
your hands
you got a lot of cheese on the plate
right the peanut butter okay can i say
something to the audience we have four
and a half
thousand people listening jarrah showed
up did you bring anything
rapid tony no did you bring anything
this
you brought a bottle of water pat
brought a crew
okay i brought some bathroom issues
jared brought liquor
four bottles of liquor uh some sort of
hummus platter
that's been fantastic with cream cheese
how come i don't know about this what do
you mean it's all over here are you
having gone over there
because she's gonna bring the snacks
okay so that's where i was hanging out
on stage in the green room on a serious
note
i salute the reason why i wanted to say
this because i salute all the bladders
in this room because we've got
three and a half hours of respect to all
of you but i think it's fair there's
gonna be a line
but having said that gang guys saw a
bunch of comments say do it again if you
want to see
it again click on the sub button put the
thumbs up and comment below thank you
everybody good night good night good
night
you